[Musik]
zwölf jahre war der pariser elyséepalast
sein zuhause
zwei amtsperioden lang prägte chirac
frankreich am abend des elften märz 2007
kündigte er seinen rückzug aus der
politik an ende einer ära für mich ist
der moment gekommen ihnen auf einem
anderen platz zu dienen
ich werde mich nicht mehr um ihre
unterstützung für ein weiteres mandat
bemühen
chirac ein örtchen in der chor es in der
tiefsten französischen provinz die
vorfahren des ehemaligen präsidenten
kamen aus dieser region er selbst besaß
ein schloss dort hier kandidierte
jacques chirac seit 1967 immer wieder
für die nationalversammlung
seinen wahlkreis verteidigte er stets
erfolgreich sozialisten und kommunisten
kamen über 20 prozent nicht hinaus
bürgernähe sein credo außenpolitik
europa hier spielt das alles kaum eine
rolle chirac geht die täglichen
schwierigkeiten der region an
jugendarbeitslosigkeit probleme der
bauern landflucht in seinen
wahlversammlungen stimmt das politische
feine welt
die sozialisten und kommunisten haben
auf nationaler und teilweise auch auf
regionaler ebene nichts neues oder gar
fortschrittliches verwirklicht applaus
für den weltgewandten chirac
die menschen vertrauen ihm
premierminister nennen sie ihn auch
jahre später noch das amt hatte er von
1974 bis 76 erstmals in einen
vertrauensbonus der bleibt bei den
knorrigen menschen der chor es allemal
das lothringer kreuz sind colombo musik
ließ am denkmal für schall de gaulle
demonstriert dessen politischer enkel
jacques chirac geschichtsbewusstsein wie
kontinuität gleichermaßen das kreuz
zeichen des widerstands gegen nazi
deutschland aber auch symbol für den
europäischen neuanfang unter georges
pompidou macht chirac seine ersten
politischen schritte ihn erkennt er an
als legitimen erben des großen generals
mit valerie skd star dagegen dem dritten
präsidenten der fünften republik hat
chirac akzeptanzprobleme er bricht mit
ihm gründete 1985 seine eigene
politische partei die ware gaullistische
bewegung bulldozer rücksichtslos
karriere süchtig attribute die ihn
seither begleiten unter dem
sozialistischen präsidenten françois
mitterrand wird er 1986 zum zweiten mal
regierungschef kohabitation nennt sich
diese zusammenarbeit gegensätzlicher
politischer lager sie scheitert 1988 18
jahre lang von 1977 bis 95 bleibt das
pariser rathaus sein arbeitsplatz
bürgermeister chirac verschafft der
metropole glanz und ansehen polit wie
showprominenz gäste die auch ihm
regelmäßige medienpräsenz garantieren
[Applaus]
der politische alltag dagegen oft genug
bloße tristesse
allerdings gelingt es chirac auch hier
politische pflöcke einzuschlagen
in einem streit um die geplante
abholzung kranke bäume auf dem monat
etwa kann sich der gewiefte taktiker
chirac als umweltaktivist positionieren
1990 war das als auch in frankreich
grüne ideen oftmals noch mitleidig
belächelt wurden auf einer
pressekonferenz macht chirac alle knapp
500.000 pariser bäume zur chefsache
ein punktsieg in sachen popularität die
früchte jacques chirac reifen dennoch
langsam beim sprung ins präsidentenamt
scheitert er 1981 wie 88 an francois
mitterrand im dritten anlauf kann er
1995 schließlich triumphieren
das bad in der menge
[Applaus]
staatsmann wird chirac erst an seinem
ersten tag im neuen amt weil es
frankreich gibt muss es in der
weltpolitik machen
der auftrag des general de gaulle
jacques chirac der erbe kann sie die
champs élysées seine triumph meile
was zählt ist macht chirac lebt das aus
[Musik]
der wechsel im élysée bedeutet eine
tiefe zäsur
der neue ein macher gewählt wird
zunächst sieben jahre 2002 mit über 80
prozent eindrucksvoll im amt bestätigt
für eine neuerdings auf fünf jahre
verkürzte periode mit françois
mitterrand tritt ein visionär ab er
wirkte oft abgehoben sonnenkönig nannte
man ihn ehrfürchtig aber auch spöttisch
in jedem fall ein titel der einem
sozialisten eigentlich fremd sein sollte
bei hofe weht unter chirac ein anderer
wind absetzbewegungen
die 14 jahre die präsident mitterrand
geprägt hat sind vorbei
ich möchte dass die franzosen von anfang
an erkennen dass der erhoffte wechsel
stattgefunden hat
den flugzeugträger fonds hatte zwar
präsident mitterrand in die adria
verlegt aber erst chirac nutzte die
präsenz um sich energisch in die balkan
politik der weltgemeinschaft
einzumischen
er war die treibende kraft hinter der
schnellen eingreiftruppe
er schickte französische soldaten keine
blauhelme die seiner meinung nach
ohnehin nur zur hilflosigkeit verurteilt
waren
chirac korrigierte frankreichs pro
serbische politik slobodan milosevic
serbiens staatschef galt nicht länger
als seriöser gesprächspartner bei der
beendigung des bruder kampfes im
ehemaligen jugoslawien chirac ruft 1999
zu friedenskonferenz nach rom wo er
letzte wenngleich erfolglos gebliebene
chance den kosovo krieg doch noch
abzuwenden
pariser zeitungen kommentieren den
kurswechsel so frankreich ist endlich
zurück auf der weltbühne buddhismus pur
ein ebenso entschlossenes signal hat
chirac auch in frankreich gesetzt bei
der gedenkfeier zur erinnerung an die
13.000 französischen juden die 1942 in
paris zusammengetrieben und nach
auschwitz deportiert wurden
macht er schluss mit der von mitterrand
gepflegten verdrängung der französischen
mitschuld an diesen verbrechen
der kriminelle wahnsinn der besatzer
wurde von franzosen und dem
französischen staat unterstützt
erkenntnis zu verstrickungen in dunkler
vergangenheit
unmittelbar nach amtsantritt reiste
chirac ins frankofone afrika auch hier
der getreue nachlassverwalter der goltz
der auch nach der entkolonialisierung
ganz ungeniert einfluss für frankreich
in dieser region reklamierte
das haben auch andere präsidenten vor
chirac so gesehen aber er hat bei dieser
tour sowohl die gastgeber wie die eigene
delegation mit ganz ungewöhnlichen
vorschlägen zum schuldenerlass
überrascht frankreich so heißt die
botschaft wird wieder mehr in seine
ureigenste interessenpolitik investieren
unter den farben blau weiß rot
die grande nation auch auf militärischem
sektor wieder sichtbar zu machen war ein
hauptanliegen des jacques chirac die
force de frappe die atomstreitmacht zur
see wurde massiv ausgebaut
die raketen sprengköpfe modernisiert der
sozialistische präsident françois
mitterrand hatte noch ein atomtest
moratorium verfügt nachfolger chirac
hatte das als schweren politischen
fehler gegeißelt den er folgerichtig
korrigiert
fünfter september 1995 gegen allen
internationalen protest nimmt frankreich
auf dem mururoa-atoll wieder atomtest
soft deutliche signale an den rest der
welt seismographische verwerfungen
werden bewusst kalkuliert chirac uhr auf
einem sonderweg war chirac auch zu
zeiten des irak krieges 2003
friedensbewegte rieben sich verwundert
die augen über den neuen bundesgenossen
den konflikt um saddam hussein
zugeschriebene biologische und
bakteriologische waffen wollte direkt
mit hilfe der uno und auf friedlichem
wege lösen kriegs airbus musste seine
achse des bösen neu definieren
am vierzigsten jahrestag des deutsch
französischen freundschaftsvertrag
hatten beide seiten beschlossen an
keinem waffengang am golf teilzunehmen
die transatlantischen beziehungen
erlebten ihre größte krise
[Musik]
schicksalsgemeinschaft europa
das einvernehmen ist herzlich doch
hinter der fassade kracht es gewaltig
ausgerechnet im eu gründungsland
frankreich führt 2005 die geplante eu
verfassung bei einem referendum durch 54
eineinhalb prozent der wahlberechtigten
sagten nein zu mehr kompetenzen für
europa das ergebnis markiert den anfang
vom ende der ära chirac potenzielle
nachfolger noch laufen sich warm
der präsident schmallippig frankreich
hat sich demokratisch entschieden sie
haben mehrheitlich die europäische
verfassung zurückgewiesen das ist ihre
souveräne entscheidung und ich nehme das
zur kenntnis
ein misstrauensvotum für jacques chirac
und seine politik der nicht eingelösten
versprechungen
so werteten viele beobachter das
ergebnis des referendums
der präsident reagierte nachhaltig
schockiert zwar opferte er seinen
premierminister ging aber ansonsten auf
tauchstation
kein wort zu den pariser vorstadt
krawallen des jahres 2005 kein wort zu
den millionen protesten wegen
gravierender gesetzlicher änderungen in
der arbeitsmarktpolitik 2006 nach
wochenlangen landesweiten
straßenschlachten kassierte er
schließlich das entsprechende gesetz und
düpierte so seinen premierminister der
alte kampfgeist schien dahin ein lange
offenes kapitel die korruptionsvorwürfe
gegen jacques chirac veruntreuung
öffentlicher gelder vertrauensmissbrauch
illegale vorteilsnahme ein verfahren
meist ohne den angeklagten auf kosten
der stadt paris so das gericht
beschäftigte chirac 28 personen die in
wirklichkeit für seine partei arbeiteten
oder denen er eine gefälligkeit erweisen
wollte mitglieder des französischen
staats adels gehörten dazu etwa ein
enkel von general de gaulle der prozess
sein jahrelanges kräftemessen zwischen
unabhängiger justiz und politik die
staatsanwaltschaft plädierte auf
freispruch wohl auf höhere weisung ende
2011 er ging dennoch ein urteil
zwei jahre haft auf bewährung ein
beispielloser fall in frankreich
chirac gesundheitlich seit langem
beeinträchtigten haben das urteil an
ein sieg des rechts über die
staatsraison so die vorherrschende
meinung am 16 mai 2007 übergab jacques
chirac sein amt an nachfolger nicolas
sarkozy
anlass für ein letztes wort an die
nation
[Musik]
ich möchte ihnen sagen was für eine
große ehre ist für mich war es ihnen
gedient zu haben
der abschied von der großen bühne ein
tag ohne große gesten jacques chirac ein
homo politicus über 45 jahre gehörte er
zum politikbetrieb seines landes er hat
frankreich maßgeblich geprägt